all right y'all before we go let's take
a quick dive into the world of social
media this is what I'm
liking the holidays can be mostly
magical but for some of us extra time
with family means a few extra curse
words it happened that's where Auntie
Bev comes in uh this former journalist
and educator started a Tik Tok Channel
teaching vocabulary words she's
encouraging everyone to curse with class
this holiday season nice so you want to
call somebody a hoe they're licentious
you want to call somebody
a they are um vagos or termagants if you
want to call a man a hoe because there's
some men male holes out there too those
can be either LS l u t or lotharios
you're just a
lario love her let's get aie B in here
she's watching on W L TV and Raleigh
Durham what's
up hey Kelly Hi how are you oh my go I I
am obsessed with you I'm G to lead with
that I do know some louds um but try
what so you're you're trying to help at
Christmas time right absolutely because
I don't know about your family but let
me tell you about my family uh full
disclosure
here we have those family members who
come over and you know they've already
had a lot to drink and then they come
over and they have more eggnog and they
just become totally obnoxious and you
want to bite your tongue because you
know you want to cuss them out not curse
them out because cursing is the
formality cuss them out is the hood
version so when you want to cuss them
out you call them alumic just ask them
to just stop being alumic we don't need
that so so what you want to tell Grandma
as opposed to just being upset and
saying you know Grandma you need to sit
your down and shut up say Grandma this
is your day you don't need to be a
herodan now a herodan is a bossy strict
old belligerent woman so instead of
saying that you just say grandma don't
be a herodin and then you have the male
cousins who come over and they're
hitting on everybody until they realize
you're their
cousin they're lario so you just say hey
look lario I'm your cousin I'm your
sister's niece so you have to come up
with a lot of different classier words
in order to say the same kinds of things
you would say when you're using the four
felter nasty words yes here's the
I wish that I were spending Christmas
with you because you are hysterical I
like the words I like it sometimes you
need the real ones but try and keep it
classy America okay thank you so much
Auntie be I'm liking your PO right now
that's not all though our season long
partner pilot pin makers of precise the
goto pin of the Kelly Clarkson show want
to celebrate people who make the
holidays a little less dramatic and more
fun and that is you ma'am so they are
giving you $1,000 how's that sound
thank you so much I see them have such a
great holiday
[Music]
[Applause]
season thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home